monday august 9 hiatus edition of pft
live slash pftpm we'll be back on
peacock and nbcsn
next monday the crew getting a
well-deserved week off in the aftermath
of the olympics but the olympics are
over you can focus fully and completely
on football as if you weren't focused as
much as you could be already on football
but now there's no impediment in the
sports world forget about those other
sports like baseball and really nothing
else is happening right now so football
it is preseason games coming some news
from over the weekend and monday morning
to keep you up to speed on everything
happening in the nfl let's begin with
something that
john mcclane of the houston chronicle
tweeted
mid-morning on monday
deshaun watson will not play another
down for the houston texans now that
comes at a time when people like charles
robinson of yahoo are suggesting that
the texans are going to try
to get watson to change his mind about
wanting out
hopeful that his hold in will become
something more than that that he'll
return to practice that he'll be all in
with the team and that the efforts to
trade him will stop what's happened over
the course the past two weeks is fairly
simple watson showed up
two sundays ago actually technically
three sundays ago 15 days ago the next
day multiple reports indicating that
texans are now trying to trade him nfl
media making it known loud and clear and
far and wide that the texans are ready
to trade and they've been ready to trade
it well the problem is the texans
haven't gotten the kind of offer that
they wanted they expect as one executive
remarked at the time
the clock to be set to the middle of
january when maybe it would have been
three first round picks plus for deshaun
watson now it's different it's different
because
of 22 civil lawsuits 10 criminal
complaints and the inevitability of a
grand jury watson's camp believes not if
but when a grand jury will happen all it
takes is one felony indictment and
desean watson will most likely be put on
paid leave and
done with football until the criminal
case is over that's what is keeping
teams from making the kind of offer that
the texans want
and it should cause the texans to
be willing to take less if they're
willing to move on from deshaun watson
in light of the current uncertainty
otherwise you just wait
wait to see what happens with the
criminal process wait to see whether
there is an indictment wait to see
whether or not there's a trial wait to
see how long you have to pay desean
watson to not play football this year
the price is 10 million next year it's
35 million so if the texans are going to
try to slow play this now
they need to guess right as to what's
going to happen with these serious legal
issues that are swirling around to sean
watson and they also have to be
comfortable putting him out there on the
field if he chooses to play
given the
lawsuits given the criminal complaints
it is not an easy process and not an
easy decision for anyone involved and
there are some real
issues that still have to be worked out
and it appears that the texans are
content
to wait even if it means spending 45
million or more
content to wait because
if they hold on to desean watson long
enough they can eventually trade him
with the legal process
completely resolved and
watson able to return to the nfl and
that is the belief that at some point
this will be over that at some point he
will be back in the nfl but the one
caveat and
there's a lot of things that have to
happen before we get to this point but
the one caveat is if there is a grand
jury when there is a grand jury if there
is an indictment
if there is a trial if there is a
conviction
desean watson may not be available to
play football for a very long time
that's part of the reality here that's
part of the risk the texans are assuming
by not getting what they can
and moving on and now pivoting to this
hope that they can get to sean watson to
play pending a decision by the nfl to
possibly put him on paid leave pending
the outcomes of these various cases and
we'll see how it goes but nothing about
it has been predictable and one of the
reasons is frankly the texans at some
level continue to be inherently
dysfunctional and and look what one very
real dynamic here and i think i've
mentioned this before
new gm nick casario would rather do no
deal than a bad deal and there is a
dynamic
among
the former bill belichick lieutenants
who become coaches or general managers
with other teams
they obsess
over what bill is going to think
about the things they do
and if you do a bargain basement deal
for deshaun watson and then a grand jury
is impaneled and then no indictment
happens and he's free and clear to keep
playing and the cases get resolved the
civil cases after the season
and what have you gotten for deshaun
watson not nearly enough so that's part
of the reason why i think the texans are
are waiting even though they may end up
waiting
and wading into a mess that they may not
be able to get themselves out of
speaking of messes that may be difficult
to get out of michael thomas and the
saints relationship
fractured now this is no surprise if
you've been paying attention to the
saints and michael thomas dating back to
last season because there were reports
during the period of time that he was
out with a badly sprained ankle that the
team was unhappy with him that he'd
become kind of a diva he'd been hard to
deal with he had treated certain people
in the organization in a way that the
organization didn't appreciate and it
didn't flame remember he had the fight
at pratt and then he was kind of
suspended kind of not suspended at a
time when it looked like maybe he was
coming back from the ankle injury we
reported back at or about the trade
deadline that thomas's camp was trying
to get other teams to make a trade offer
to the new orleans saints not that the
saints would have accepted and not that
it was successful no one made an offer
but there has been
this dysfunction that has been
percolating under the surface for a
while and now it's out in the open
with the saints
upset with thomas because
he basically went awol as it relates to
his ankle injury and whether or not it
needed surgery remember the story and
the details first came from nick
underhill of new orleans football.com
that michael thomas went to a specialist
after the season the specialist
recommended some exercises some rehab
give it a month come back and we'll see
whether or not you need surgery
and then thomas never came back over the
weekend jeff duncan of nola.com reported
that
thomas basically was ignoring
phone calls from coach sean payton from
the training staff and then come june
it was too late to get the surgery done
so he'd be ready to go to the start of
the season surgery gets done
in june and he's not ready to go and
he's not going to be ready to go
and
i i think what's happened here is
and the latest flashpoint was thomas's
tweet suggesting that the team is trying
to hurt his reputation and that he
hasn't said anything i think the reality
is the saints would have preferred to
keep all of this under wraps as long as
possible we didn't hear a peep
of
frustration or anything from the saints
back when these things were happening
when sean payton can't get in touch with
michael thomas it and go public with
that to try to shame him into responding
to phone calls when the surgery didn't
happen until june there was no reporting
that the saints were upset that this
didn't happen sooner i think the saints
not necessarily trying to smooth things
over i think the saints trying to
bolster trade value they don't want to
tear this guy down because they
eventually may want someone to trade for
him
and it got to the point where the
situation is too fractured there's too
many people talking about it jeff duncan
finally became aware of it maybe sean
payton or somebody else with the saints
at his or her wit's end and decided to
make it known what was going on behind
the curtain but regardless it's in the
saints interest to not make this work
it's it works it's in the saints
interest
to create the impression that thomas is
just the completion of his rehab away
from being good to go 100 physically
healthy and able to be traded but i
can't rule out
a trade of michael thomas by the week
eight trade deadline in 2021 if he's
healthy and if another team is
comfortable inheriting
a guy who
not long after getting paid by the
saints for whatever reason
had a falling out with the team
it's always one of my concerns
if if you
trade for a guy
who reached an impasse with his former
team
you step into the shoes of that team and
you potentially become the team that
he's upset with
in the future case in point dwayne brown
currently staying away from the seahawks
well the seahawks got dwayne brown
several years ago because he wasn't
happy with the texans refusal to give
him a new contract what's he want now a
new contract and he's not there so uh
that's part of the risk that you assume
when you trade for a guy and i think one
of the reasons why the saints
were hoping to keep as much of this
under wraps as possible they want
someone to take michael thomas and give
them maximum return and allow them to
move on and it feels
like that is inevitable something is
inevitable and the best outcome would be
finding a new home for michael thomas
via trade that gives the saints some
compensation for moving that contract
forward speaking of contracts the news
came on friday afternoon josh allen the
first quarterback from the class of 2018
to get his long-term reward in my
assessment of the deal
we have the full details of pft i'm not
gonna break them down dollar for dollar
here but it feels like a deal halfway
between dak prescott's contract and
patrick mahomes contract mahomes last
year signed a 12-year deal prescott this
year signed a four-year deal here's
allen eight years with a lot of the
mechanisms that the patrick mahomes deal
has that gives the players some security
and avoids
the year to year
reality that the packers have with aaron
rodgers because typically what happens
is and i'm going to keep it as simple as
possible
in a given year in march
money is guaranteed as of march into the
second season not just that season but
the season beyond so you do have a
commitment now guy can still be traded
guy can still be cut subject to the
guarantee
but it's a greater degree of security
for the player than what aaron rodgers
has in green bay where the packers have
him under a year to your arrangement and
that i think was one of the causes of
the consternation for rogers mahomes has
protection against it
allen has protection against it dak
prescott doesn't need it because he did
a four-year deal in three years the
cowboys either gonna give him a new
contract or face the reality he'll be on
the open market
after four seasons and it's always
better to get back
to the to the trough
sooner than later whether it's to get
back for a renegotiation or whether it's
to get back for a new contract for alan
it's probably six years until he's in
a spot where he would get a new contract
it's eight years until he's a free agent
that's still a long time
and it would have seemed like a
ridiculously long time but for the
patrick mahomes 12-year contract but it
shows the commitment that alan is
willing to make to the city of buffalo
and dollar for dollar year for year
the cash flow under the allen deal is
excellent in the short term patrick
holmes eventually catches up and by
year eight he actually is a little bit
ahead of allen but in the first one two
three four years alan makes a lot more
money i mean a lot more money than
patrick holmes makes in the first one
two three four years of his deal the
question becomes
what does the allen deal mean
for the other two guys who are expected
to get second contracts from the class
of 2018 the quarterbacks baker mayfield
and lamar jackson i think the browns are
probably going to wait on mayfield
the browns will never say this
but
my guess is they don't want to end up in
a carson wentz or a jared goff situation
where they get mayfield a long-term deal
and then one or two years later they're
wishing they hadn't now the flip side is
if mayfield has an mvp caliber season
it's going to cost a lot more next year
but i don't think we know yet with
certainty whether or not mayfield is on
that track the bills knew what they had
in josh allen and it would have been
foolish for the bills to not pay him now
they knew
what they had the browns i don't think
they know and i think that that makes
everyone inclined to wait
and maybe mayfield will have the kind of
year it makes the browns say well geez
we should have paid him last year we're
going to pay him now but there's always
that risk once you pay the guy there's
going to be some regression there's
always that risk but i think the bills
feel comfortable taking that risk the
browns maybe don't feel comfortable
taking that risk currently a year from
now maybe they will
then there's lamar jackson different
issue all together
with lamar jackson
number one
not represented by an agent
number two
allen has gone before jackson and now
lamar jackson could take a look at that
contract and say
why don't we just scratch out
josh allen
put in lamar jacks why don't we scratch
out buffalo bills put in baltimore
ravens and you know what
if i'm lamar jackson
that is a pretty good contract i think
i'd take that contract if i'm the ravens
i'm not sure
that i get myself into these multiple
years of guaranteed money well into the
future that's going to be part of this
ongoing push and pull and i think that
that the ravens are going to try to
distance themselves from josh allen's
contract i think the comments from john
harbaugh on monday that the alan deal
doesn't mean anything to lamar jackson
it doesn't increase the urgency or
whatever
i think that is an indication
subtly from the ravens that
they're they're not all that thrilled
about the prospect of lamar jackson
saying just give me the josh allendy
but uh that that's quite possibly what
will happen and maybe lamar jackson
doesn't get a deal done
and maybe
we're doing this again next year as he
enters the fifth season of his rookie
contract and
look
i think the ravens
are as sold on jackson
as the bills are on allen apart from the
skill undeniable 2019 nfl mvp and the
fact that they've basically
reconstructed their entire offense
to fit the skills and abilities of lamar
jackson they're all in with jackson
the longer they wait the more it's going
to cost the problem is and no one from
the ravens will say this because i feel
like
they're trying to defuse the bomb here
they're delicately clipping wires and
you don't want to say the wrong thing
you don't want to make the wrong move
because
you're dealing directly with the player
and you don't want to piss the player
off unnecessarily and inflame the
situation and the balance is and we've
made this point before
you don't want to do so
great of a deal for the team taking
advantage of the fact that the player
isn't represented we also don't want to
just give money away you don't want to
do a bad deal for the team because the
player isn't represented so i think this
jackson situation
more complicated than meets the eye
throw in the fact that he's had coveted
twice in less than a year and he's
not vaccinated
and we haven't heard a peep from john
harbaugh about that behind the scenes he
may be livid about it but they've got to
be very careful and i feel like there's
a certain amount of tip-toeing that
they're doing as an organization around
lamar jackson because of his importance
to the team his undeniable ability the
fact that he's not represented and the
fact that he's not vaccinated and like
way too many other nfl players don't
realize
the very real competitive disadvantage
that comes from not being vaccinated so
we'll see how that all plays out but
kudos to josh allen i think it's a great
deal for him and we'll see whether that
results in a new contract for lamar
jackson before we get to the start of
the regular season
inevitably jackson allen maybe mayfield
and others currently playing we'll make
it to the hall of fame
hall of fame ceremony over the weekend
complicated by the pandemic
i don't know that back to back nights
i i just just overload i look at this
from the perspective of the average fan
too many speeches too many busts too
much pomp too much circumstance maybe
they should have had two weekends over
the course of the summer and then i see
the videos and the photographs from the
parties and
you know look
have we forgotten we're in a pandemic i
don't know who's vaccinated who isn't
vaccinated but
we are back at a point where
in many jurisdictions
there's
a push back toward being ultra careful
wearing masks indoors and there's a
disconnect when you see some of these
images especially indoors outdoors is
different indoors and it's like there's
not even anything
untoward or
unusual happening when it relates to
public health so uh regardless
we had two nights of it back to back in
canton this year and the one
shining development
from the 2020 slash 2021 hall of fame
induction process
the creation and enforcement of strict
time limits
six minutes with an eight minute cut off
although some folks strayed past it and
this has been a subject of debate for a
while there are people out there who
believe
that
earning a spot in the hall of fame
also entitles the hall of famer to stand
up there for as long as he wants and as
i've said time and again just because
the bust is there for all eternity
doesn't mean the speech has to feel like
it is too
there's a reason for keeping it brief
there's a reason for making it
manageable this is a tv show a live tv
show and i've said all along either
create real time limits or
go ahead and let them take as much time
as they want in the afternoon tape it
trim it down
to an allotment per guy
and then play it at night if you want to
do it that way because if it's going to
be a tv show there has to be some
sensitivity to the reality that it can't
be c-span and it can't just be
filibustering and i know it's a
challenge there's so many people you
want to thank well you know what you can
thank them privately there are different
ways to show gratitude
getting up in front of
anyone who happens to be watching on nfl
network or espn and saying the name of
someone aloud so all these people out
here just waiting for this damn thing to
get over with
can hear it i don't know that that's the
proper way to thank someone and
my my approach
uh or at least my advice i i don't i
don't
i really don't enjoy public speaking in
part because now this is different
i mean this is something that i hope
that you want to listen to you wouldn't
be here if you didn't want to hear what
i had to say
when you speak at an event like that
and i've been at enough of these things
graduations
you got your program and you're just
checking boxes until the
we get to get up and leave moment of the
proceedings
so
everyone who speaks and i understand the
whole purpose of the hall of fame
ensuring is to hear from the hall of
famers
but how much are people really listening
to
and i'm a proponent of keeping it short
and striving to come up
with one memorable thing just one thing
because
at most when you're in a setting like
that especially with six seven eight
speeches the most that you can hope for
the audience to remember of what any one
person says is one thing
come up with that one thing build your
speech around that one thing make it
some theme some message beginning middle
end and keep it all as tight together as
possible say what you have to say
and move on
and the other thing too
because i got the impression
that peyton manning who definitely
respected the rules of the hall of fame
was rushing a little bit
don't don't don't don't rush the
delivery that is your moment you don't
want to be stressed out about the fact
that you only have six minutes got a lot
of ground to cover
got a long way to go in a short time to
get there that can't be the attitude the
attitude is
i got six to eight minutes
you prepare four minutes
and you take your time delivering it
that's what you do because
you want to remember that moment
as your moment however long or short it
is that's your moment
and
if you're stressed out the whole time
because you got more to say and you
don't have enough time to say it that
doesn't make it an enjoyable moment
anyway that's just my
that's my free advice definitely
guaranteed to get your money's worth if
you follow it preseason has started
and
i i
i i angered some people the other night
by something that i tweeted and i've
been waiting for an opportunity to talk
it through a little bit more and this
isn't an excuse by any means i mean this
is an attitude that i've had about the
preseason for years
dating back to at least
the first time i heard the commissioner
complaining about the quality of the
preseason what happens though is and i
see it on social media this relentless
hype machine
about pre-season football
uh look let's just accept the preseason
for what it is
the pre-season is
an opportunity for teams to
to get acclimated to what it's going to
be like on game day you go through the
game day ritual the pre-game routine
and it's an opportunity for some of the
veteran players to to take some reps and
knock the rust off although teams are
being more and more careful about their
veterans in the preseason and then it
becomes an opportunity for
younger players who know they're
inevitably going to be cut
to create game film that will get them
on a practice squad get them picked up
on waivers by another team get them a
phone call in september october november
december or whatever this is their
chance to shine
in the closest thing to a real nfl game
as they're ever going to see that's what
the preseason is and i appreciate that
and i respect that
when
i see
people in the media when i see team
social media accounts trying to equate
pre-season to the regular season that's
when i say folks we need to be
honest
with ourselves and with our audience
isn't it enough
for just to accept football in the
preseason for what it is
it's not regular season football the
commissioner repeatedly has said it's
not reflective of the high standards of
the national football league now part of
his reason for doing that was to say
we'll give up one of the preseason games
and have an extra regular season game
and i guarantee you they stuck with
three this year instead of two
because they want to hold that ability
to go from three to two as leverage and
as the trade-off when the regular season
goes as it will from 17 to 18.
but
we saw last year no preseason at all and
the veterans would prefer no preseason
at all and
did we miss
the only thing i i the only thing that i
i really like about preseason football
is seeing rookie quarterbacks do they
check the box do they pass the eyeball
test do they look like they belong how
does the ball look coming out of their
hand i remember with kyle murray a
couple of years ago zip coming out and
zip going in and he looks the part the
game's not too big for him
we'll be doing that this year with
justin fields kellen monde
all the rookie quarterbacks that we
expect to see in the pre-season trey
lance my god everything trey lance does
is going to be
under a microscope is he ready to take
over for jimmy garoppolo does he look
the part zach wilson does he look the
part trevor lawrence does he look the
part is he ready to go that's where the
preseason value is and
i just
you know
social media is a cesspool of negativity
and uh it's also at times a cesspool of
excessive unrealistic positivity
i just like to keep it realistic
i know what the preseason is i know what
the pre-season is not and i reacted the
other night frankly to the fact that i
saw all these people acting like
the return of preseason football was
somehow the same as the return
of regular season football and we know
that that's not the case we know that
last year the disappearance of 65
preseason games meant nothing to the
product that we saw
come september when the real game
started so
that that's how that all happened and
look okay people get upset and some
former players or hey look i i
understand why they think that i was
saying what i was saying and i own what
i said but my point is
sometimes
that that hype machine just irritates me
because it crosses the line into snake
oil sales
let's not lie to the people about what
this really is and there's value in it
but let's not lie to the people about
what it is we know what it is
we know what it isn't all right
let's answer some questions on this
monday hiatus edition of pft live slash
pftpm let's see we got here
let's see what we got
looking back through i did the tweet
earlier today so i got to scroll through
some of that we got a lot of content up
today let's see where is the office gift
that here it is uh all right let's
answer some questions let me get this
going here
all right
um
burn unit if desean watson is on the
commissioner exemplist for a season does
that count as an accrued season under
his contract um
you know all i know is he gets paid
he gets paid for the full season i don't
know if it counts as an accrued season i
think it does i think the only thing he
loses is the ability to play the the
nfl's position has been that there is no
element of punishment to being on the
commissioner exempt list so that would
tell me it does not affect his status or
standing in any way he's on the team
he's getting paid he's just not
permitted to play because frankly the
nfl doesn't want to have to deal with
the pr fallout of having a guy who is
facing serious allegations being on the
tv screen and being the subject of
discussion
despite all constitutional protections
innocent until proven guilty and whatnot
they reserve the right under certain
circumstances based on certain
accusations even if they are never
proven
to say that guy can't be on the field
because it makes us uncomfortable if he
is on the field
jr the boss man the nba is investigating
the miami heat and the chicago bills for
the chicago bulls bill's bull into who
we mean
for tampering prior to free agency when
are leagues like the nba and nfl going
to get rid of these tampering rules well
the nfl
kind of did with the 48 hour or however
long it is i think it starts it at noon
on a monday and lasts until four
on a wednesday so it's a 52-hour period
where it's permissible to negotiate and
unofficially finalize contracts before
free agency begins and what we see every
year is
a large percentage of the deals are done
before the process starts the nfl did
that because it was so glaring that
tampering was happening for example
albert haynesworth 2009 free agency
started at midnight on a friday by 5 a.m
he had 100 million contract negotiated
that didn't get negotiated from scratch
between the hours of midnight and 5 a.m
so the nfl
as a way to kind of acknowledge that
this happens
and
and
deciding to create a window for it to
happen
it's able to continue to ignore the fact
that it happens well in advance and it
mainly happens at the scouting combine
in indianapolis and people make no bones
about it it's all untraceable it's all
face-to-face meetings in hotel rooms
there's no way to know who's talking to
whom about what and uh nobody cares how
bruce erin's blatantly tampered with tom
brady last year at the scouting combine
telling reporters they're gonna call tom
brady that's a tampering violation
the nfl either
doesn't care or the nfl and i think the
truth is
the nfl doesn't enforce the rule
aggressively because number one there's
no way to enforce it fairly because
everyone breaks it and number two
the nfl doesn't really want to be in a
position where it is informing the world
on a regular basis that we have corrupt
organizations
at some point
if you penalize every tampering
violation if you penalize every injury
report violation at some point
somebody's going to say
man
did they all cheat we should do
something about this all these teams
cheat i think that's one of the reasons
why the nfl looks the other way so i
think it's going to continue to happen
it and uh
period
end of statement they're not going to do
anything to change it and i don't know
anything about the nba situation but in
the nfl
unless somebody
is
over the top
clear blatant tampering
kind of like bruce arians last year even
then i don't know if the nfl is going to
do anything about it
all right
what do we have here
jr the boss man what do players need to
do to understand contracts better and
not just trust what their agent or the
team says so they won't sign a deal that
the market bypasses in two or three
years and then be upset and wanting an
adjustment to the deal this is the
xavian howard situation and kudos to the
dolphins and david cantor who represents
xavier however coming up with some sort
of a middle ground where he can
return to the team or at least return to
practice he was holding in not holding
out
um
this is a dynamic that happens from time
to time in the nfl
and the dolphins were guilty of it with
xavier howard the window opens on a
second contract
the team swoops in
cobbles together a deal
that looks good for now
and what they did was
with a five-year extension they loaded
up the money in a way that made the new
money average just a hair above josh
norman who at the time was making 15
million a year they got xavier howard to
15.05 million per year in new money i
wrote about the problems with the deal
at the time
agent wasn't happy about it oh well
but that new money analysis can be used
to really warp the value of the deal and
if the kid doesn't understand it
and look every agent wants to be able to
use
perceived success on behalf of one
client as a way to attract more clients
i remember when colin kaepernick second
contract happened in 2014.
it was sold as the greatest contract
ever signed by any player once you
scratch at the surface it just wasn't
it's very common for agents to try to
oversell these deals the problem is
sometimes you do get a player who
ascends in one of the seasons after he
signs the deal he's at a point where
he's not happy with the deal maybe the
market's passed him by maybe you have a
player on your team that has gotten you
know as much or more money than you and
byron jones who was signed as a free
agent and you're not happy and and see
that's why whether it's a trade or
whether it's a free agent contract you
never want to be the team
that does too good of a deal
you want the player to be happy with the
contract that he signed for as long as
he possibly can be you want the team
that you did that trade with to be happy
with what what it got
makes it harder to do deals
if you're doing deals that are too good
and the dolphins did a deal by virtue of
the fact that they were willing to do
anything to rectify that's an admission
they knew they did too good of a deal
with xavier howard and he outperformed
that deal and to their credit
they fixed it
and the biggest offenders
were the eagles of the
early 2000s when joe banner was the team
president and they seemed to believe
that they gave out lombardi trophies
based upon how much salary cap you could
save they would target players early in
their careers
they would make them offers that they
could not refuse
and those contracts were destined
through the passage of time to become
bad contracts and that happened with
several players who were not happy
excuse me i was holding that off as long
as i could but several players ended up
being unhappy you don't want that you
always want your players to be happy
with their deals
v venit at venit virginia can you ask
tony dungy why the vikings didn't draft
john lynch his former college coach
dennis green could have drafted him in
the third round in 1993
that's a
that's a an interesting question
um
and uh i don't know the answer to it but
you know what that's the second player
at least that dungeon benefited from who
was passed on by the vikings because
warren sapp
2005
1995 man time has flown 1995 excuse me
tony dungy
was
uh the defensive coordinator in
minnesota was it 95 or 94
to 94 i think he became
the buccaneer's head coach in 95 but in
94
the vikings passed on warren sapp and
the buccaneers took him and tony dungy
benefited from uh dennis green and
company passing on warren sapp
lefty big guns do you have any
information about the raider situation
and the sudden departure
of multiple staff and players
i don't other than it's weird it's odd
i mean you've got several players who
have retired
and you've got several front office
people who have left we don't know why
any of them left the team president left
the guy who got the new stadium built
left just as we're getting ready to put
people in the new stadium it's odd i
don't know what's going on and there's
been no reporting about what really
happened behind the scenes but
sorry it's not normal behavior
for this to happen so it suggests that
something's not right something's not
happening properly
in the football
team as it relates to the business side
in the football operation guys retire
all the time i don't i i think it's two
different things but if there is
dysfunction in the organization it can
affect both sides but we'll just wait
and see look
i know there's some vague sense that the
raiders are going to turn things around
this year look around the afc
nine strong contenders and the raiders
aren't one of them it's going to be
tough for the raiders to get to where
they need to get this year
at burn unit when do you expect there to
be a grand jury for desean watson i
don't know all i know is his camp
believes it's inevitable and obviously
the sooner the better to get this
resolved let everyone know where things
stand but if he's indicted that's all
the sooner that he gets put on the
commissioner exempt list
all right
jr the boss man russell wilson sounds
very optimistic about the seahawks
offense how long in your mind until pete
carroll stops letting russ cook
what happened last year was
they made changes to the offense it
worked incredibly well early in the
season and then when the defenses
started to figure out the tendencies and
the tells and the patterns
the seahawks offense didn't do enough to
stay a step ahead of the defenses that's
going to be one of the challenges this
year with shane waldron whatever they're
doing
early if it works
you have to self scout yourself as sims
would say and stay a step ahead now
we've heard a lot about unpredictability
a formation from which they can run or
pass that's key you don't want to tip
off what you're doing
before the play begins
and as we get deeper and deeper into a
season
and as teams study the film
from every snap pre-season regular
season everything that's available they
start to figure out the patterns
and the smart teams with the great
defensive coordinators will start to
crack the code you need to crack your
own code and stay ahead of it and i
think last year pete carroll finally
just got to the point where it's like
look at this
this isn't working we need to be more
conservative and that laid the
foundation for all the off-season issues
and now everything's fine russell wilson
compartmentalizes it it's fine glass
half full
he thinks the seahawks can have the best
offense in football why not well if they
do great
and if they get past the division around
for the first time since 2014 even
better but if they don't i think we're
going to be back in the same spot come
february 2022 that we were in february
of 2021.
all right a lot of
a lot of great
questions here today
narendra choudhary any chance the
six-minute speaking rule will be the
standard
for the hall of fame or was this the
exception because of all the inductees
i i
i'd like to think that we've crossed a
bridge now where it becomes a standard
part it's baked in to the process
and it'll be interesting to see if they
really do play the music and cut the mic
of a guy who talks for too long but as i
said earlier
just because you've earned that spot
permanently in canton doesn't mean
you've got the right to stand up there
and filibuster for as long as you want
to go and i know that some people think
they have the right to do it i don't
as long as it's a live tv show i don't
uh jr the boss man at what point do you
believe patrick mahomes will ask for a
new contract after seeing all these
other contracts that are better than his
well dak prescott's contract clearly
better josh allen's contract better
um
excuse me i i think that
i look it it depends on first whether or
not someone passes 45 million in new
money average that's the point where
there will be a widespread presumption
that someone has a better deal than
patrick mahomes but even though he's at
45 million per year in new money the
details of the deal
make it
easy for a guy who's only making 40
million per year like dak prescott to
overcome or josh allen who's only making
only making 43 million per year and new
money his deals better but we get to a
point where somebody's making more than
45 million per year
i think that's when the pressure starts
to build on the chiefs to spot the
necessity to fix the contract and get it
done and keep him happy peter king had
some great quotes today from brett veach
the gm of the team from andy reid the
head coach and from homes himself about
how they found a way
to keep patrick homes happy across the
board involvement with personnel
involvement with coaching they're not
going to take advantage of them and
they're not going to let him think that
he's being taken advantage of when the
time comes to fix that contract i
suspect that the chiefs will do it
unless there's some major dramatic
change in the management of the team
one more good one from jr the boss man
what do you think it will take lamar
jackson to get the vaccine after getting
covered twice i i think that
for some of these guys kirk cousins
lamar jackson other starting
quarterbacks and there seem to be a few
of them that aren't vaccinated
i don't think anything's going to change
their mind and it really is amazing to
me you know what i thought would happen
this year would be
the mindset from last year that kova is
not going to affect me not worried about
covet
that that would translate to
players taking the approach they're not
worried about the vaccine vaccine can't
hurt me
and you look at it from a football
standpoint
being vaccinated
increases the chances that you'll be
available to play
decreases the chances that you're going
to have some covet test be asymptomatic
find out on the sunday morning of an
afternoon or evening game that you can't
play
getting vaccinated wipes that out i
thought players
would no questions asked give me the
vaccine what's the team want me to do
they want me to get the vaccine i'm
getting the vaccine it enhances my
availability yes give me the vaccine i'm
not worried about it i mean they line up
out the door to take toradol shots
and we know
that there are long-term serious health
effects potentially arising from tort
all use back in the rampant days of
steroids everybody knew there were
long-term effects but they needed to do
it now to ensure that they could play
getting vaccinated
increases your chances of being able to
play
so even though lamar jackson's had it
twice
even though other players who haven't
had it
but
should recognize the connection between
getting vaccinated and being available
to play they say no
it's
it's it's it's not changing
if they haven't done it yet
i don't think they're gonna do it unless
a teammate
who's not vaccinated gets seriously ill
or dies
that's the only thing i think that's
gonna break through that
that that wall that so many players have
that plexiglass that kirk cousins is
going to ensconce himself with this year
now
we're three weeks away from the roster
cuts down to 53 there's a graduated
process this year it's not all the way
at once but 90 to 53 will be completed
on tuesday august 31.
it'll be interesting to see what the
vaccinate rate vaccination rates are
on the various teams once we get to 53.
as i've said before i always thought the
vaccination rates would go up there's a
chance they're going to go down
there's a chance that the holdouts are
all guys who know that when it's time to
cut the rosters they're not going to be
released we'll see how that plays out
all right i should wrap this up but
there still are some pretty good
questions here
uh
football god if jamal adams gets a big
payday does that mean dwayne brown is on
his way out of seattle look you got to
find a way to pay everybody and they pay
russell wilson a ton of money and they
have to pay jamal adams a lot of money
i've heard about 17 million a year reset
the safety market they've given up two
first round picks to get him they've got
to pay him with dwayne brown it's a
little more delicate
you had
trent williams get what 22 million just
a little bit more than david bogtiari
this year it's gonna be a little more
delicate and and again
they ended up getting dwayne brown in
seattle because he wasn't happy with his
contract in houston and he wasn't happy
with what the texans had offered by way
of a new contract so they shouldn't be
shocked
that dwayne brown is taking that same
approach now and just like they
shouldn't be shocked that jamal adams
wants to be paid
dramatically more than the current top
safety at a time when they've given him
all the leverage traded for him gave up
the two first round picks and didn't
insist on getting a deal done then
all right
that's uh
that's it for today
um
we will be back again on peacock and
nbcsn next monday until then the goal is
to do this every day of the week we'll
have sims back maybe on wednesday maybe
i'll convince him to go two days this
week gotta get him back and he's kind of
like pre-season for him got to get him
back into you know his full-time four
day a week talking mode but to either
way
profitballtalk.com
around the clock all day every day
videos every day this week
pft live back next monday thanks as
always for some of your time we'll talk
to you again on tuesday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports